what's up guys so our mouths a buck
something interesting let me go get it
it's not a half line box but I didn't
actually open up what's inside of it I
just had to see what was in here to had
no idea now that I know
holy moly when you see this that's
interesting is that it looks like a
pizza hut logo and it's a block
honoureth the Scooby screaming it
clearly is a pizza because how would you
put me I guess you could fit a pizza in
here
I mean could Evi Pizza shoo I don't know
[Music]
my goodness like even meditation paper
is Pizza Hut themed $7.99 large -
dropping if you get this out of the way
this isn't a sponsored video but they
did send me the shoes I mean when you
get an email that says hey we'd like to
send you some shoes that order pizza
what do you say you say yes please thank
you oh my goodness
holy moly
look how did this work like supposedly
you're supposed to just push a little
button here and order you a pizza and
yeah this little tag says download the
pie pops app on your phone
pair your shoes enjoy delicious pizza
this is like the most insane thing that
I've ever seen I've seen a lot of crazy
stuff
I wonder if it fit stay on my side
download the pie [__] back all right
Oh big problem because come on pizza I
need a gdb blood for breakfast lunch
dinner snack you can feel in the tongue
of the shoes Bears put a button I love
the future but this is the future
self-lacing shoes okay Omaha shoes to
order me pizza would be look so good the
way I'm gonna wear these all the time
and people going to be like where'd you
get your shoes so if they stay sighs
where do you think I got that wait look
at my freaking shoe I have it so the
first step is to log in a second step is
to turn on your Bluetooth okay so this
press and hold the PI tops button you
pair with my phone I have it looking
very request pair it's happening so take
you to this next screen and will let you
choose the pieces that you want to have
delivered so in here it also gives you
an option of your order press style so
you can press 1 press twice or press and
hold I'm going to do press twice just to
be saved so I'm going to order a pizza
right now I'm not going to touch my
phone I don't know if I get a
notification like what happens like how
is it going to know where just get my
pizza from we're gonna try say ready 1 2
like I don't know like if the peeps are
going to show at my house I have no idea
so I guess I'm just going to edit this
video and if a piece in shows up of my
house and I'm going to edit that in
after this because I had no idea this
was going to work I know I have
absolutely no idea
we have some development so I was just
editing this video and I received a text
message that said my order has been
placed thank you for ordering pizza hutt
track your order here and throw in our
why I'm editing in my kitchen is because
I have a roof leak upstairs in my office
so this is where I've been my new office
so I'm in my shoes and what you can
repeat huh
I have newly got some people coming you
see with us says can you see that if
some of my pieces up for deliveries you
know that must mean it should be here
very very soon hi yeah
Oh Oh baby oh my god this is this is the
happiest day ever my guess it worked I
had no idea was even going to work until
I got a text message I'm so happy cheers
to the future technology is incredible
and so is pizza bye
so upon further investigation I know I
said this video is over but it looks
like once you connected your Pizza Hut
account it was connected to a credit
cards that I guess Pizza Hut had hooked
up to the PI Tops app account so once
you connected that to your pizza account
it then allows me to order the pizza on
their gift card or something because I
was so confused because I didn't have a
credit card we'll get to my pizza had to
go so that is how it happened so thank
you beautiful sweet summer shoes this is
incredible I'm going to now eat the rest
of the speed but not all of it maybe
I'll just have two more slices
[Music]
you